hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast population genomics of sex
chromosome evolution we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth I am Judy
O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on a
green join a button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button would have the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Melissa Wilson Sayers
PhD dr. Wilson sayers is an assistant
professor at the School of Life Sciences
at Arizona State University I will now
turn it over to dr. Wilson sayers for
her presentation
all right thank you very much Judy I'm
very happy to be here I was just
realizing that it's been 10 years that
I've been studying sex chromosome
evolution so it's something I've been
passionate about for a long time so what
I want to go over today is really the
importance of studying sex chromosomes
and how their evolution affects medicine
today we are now starting to really
appreciate the impact of evolution on
modern medicine and today we're going to
go through a little bit of background
about sex chromosome evolution what are
the implications of X inactivation for
medicine why I think that the Y
chromosome is not irrelevant and some
conclusions so to get started I wanted
to go through the CDC most common causes
of death for men and women and it turns
out that they differ the most common
cause their death for both men and women
is heart disease and all that affects
men a little more it still is the number
one cause of death for all people in the
u.s. and so we want to look at here is
folks the order of the disease and the
proportion of the population that it
affects so number two for both men and
women again is cancer again slightly
affecting more men than women and
although 24% may not seem as much more
than 21% when you're thinking of known
as the people this translates to
hundreds thousands of individuals so the
third leading cause of death in women is
stroke and it affects approximately 6.1
percent of women
it's time thought that stroke doesn't
show up until number five for men and if
we pause and work at the 30 line cause
of death for men it might explain the
third ailing cause of death for women
so the third bidding cause of death for
men is unintentional injuries this is a
poor joke on my hospice unintentional
injuries are the third leading cause of
death of men and in fact we don't even
show up in the top five there number six
for women both men and women are
affected significantly by chronic lower
respiratory disease or the number four
leading cause of death for both men and
women and rounding up number five so
women is alzheimer's assessing four
point seven percent of women and you'll
notice this is the only disease that
significantly affects women more than
men where we look it does not even show
up until number eight for men
so what's striking here is that there
are many diseases the leading causes of
death differ significantly between men
and women when I'm studying the genome
as a geneticist the part of the genome
that strikes me the most is the X and Y
chromosome and although all of us
inherit one copy of each chromosome from
our genetic mother and our genetic
father the sex chromosomes are not
equally represented
so genetic females have two copies of
the X and genetic males have a copy of
the x and y what's being so unique in
our genome the x and y remains fairly
poorly analyzed in genome-wide
Association studies only about 33% of
you know wide Association studies even
report analyzing the X chromosome almost
none of them include the Y chromosome
and there's some mechanistic reasons for
that but the X chromosome is a
medium-sized chromosome it's about the
size of comes from eight or nine and
it's striking that we know very little
about its role in human health and
disease so we're going to take this time
to pause and have a note about language
especially for clinicians or people who
are dealing with patients and
so throughout their talk when I talk
about my research I will talk about
genetic males to have an x and a y
chromosome in humans and genetic females
who have to ever come at them their sex
of an individual is distinct from their
gender and of all for many individuals
sex and gender will align for a
proportion of the population sex and
gender
do not align and so what I want to make
clear in this talk when I refer to males
and females I'm talking about genetic
sex and not about gender identity there
are some fascinating things to study
both with sex and gender before this
house was focusing on sex so the X and
the y chromosome are fascinating they
evolved from a pair of ancestral
autosomes that were homologous and
indistinguishable from each other
approximately 200 million years ago so
in the common ancestor of eutherian and
theory a marsupial mammals which are
together the Sirians
there was a pair of in touch with
autosomes that became sex chromosomes
and we think this happens because of the
evolution of assess length allele which
the chromosome carrying that sexcellent
allele became our Y chromosome so we
have sry sex-determining region of the Y
and over the last 200 million years the
X and the y has become extremely
differentiated from each other so what's
first apparent here is the size
difference between the X and the y
chromosome but we can also look at total
number of sites seeing human x
chromosome has about 155 million sites
on it and approximately 1100 genes
alternatively the human Y chromosome
only has 50 million sites on it so it's
significantly smaller and it has 23
unique genes there are some multi copy
gene families on the Y chromosome but in
effect and some work that we have done
and others have done and showed that the
Y chromosome has lost more than 90
percent of the gene content that it once
shared with the X chromosome
and the last part of this presentation
will talk about why we think that there
was 23 unique scenes and some of those
milk ricotta genes are still very
important for humans for medicine and
understanding believers so when we look
at the sex chromosome we'll know the
first thing that a came up will have two
large X chromosomes each have 1,100
moons on them
and genetic nails will have a large x
chromosome with 1,100 genes on it and a
small Y chromosome with approximately 22
e on it and if you imagine that each of
these scenes of equal doses and we might
wonder what are the evolutionary
consequences of unequal dosage or if
they're detrimental side effects for
having up regulation or two copies of a
gene expressed in genetic females or
with it's a one copy in genetic male and
the answer is yes actually there's some
strong evolutionary consequences to that
and one of those is the evolution of a
particular dosage compensation mechanism
in eutherian mammals we have an X
inactivation mechanism so what is X
inactivation in 1961 marry my own
suppose the random excellent activation
hypothesis but in genetics and mouse
will have sooners x chromosomes we want
to build as FEMA funds will be randomly
chosen to be inactivated and we observed
this so if we can look at the picture
with the two x chromosomes you can see
that kind of darkly stained blob on the
side of the cells in their nucleus that
dark blob is a silenced X chromosome so
in typical genetically typical females
who have two x chromosomes one of the X
chromosomes in silence into this ball of
heterochromatin in 1963
Mary bar identified these sea slugs as
our bodies and so you can actually take
a cheek swab but if you have a single x
or two x's or more and you can't look at
it under a microscope and observe your
bar bodies or not
your body's depending on your number of
X chromosomes so in fact the number of
bar bodies form relates directly to the
number of X chromosomes that exist so an
individual who has an X and a Y
chromosome will not have any bar body an
individual who has two X chromosomes
will form one bar body so one silenced X
chromosome an individual with two x's
and a why this is Klinefelter syndrome
so these individuals typically present
male and individualists x XY will have
one bar body because there's one X you
have two X chromosomes one in excess are
additionally individuals with 3 X
chromosomes try something X will form 2
bar body we can also imagine Turner
syndrome so an individual with a single
X chromosome will not have any bar
bodies formed so in 2005 Carolin village
looks across the inactive X chromosome
because it was previously presumed that
all of the genes on that bar body we
were silent was subject to silent think
that it was a chromosome wide mechanism
and the entire silence the entire
inactive X chromosome was silence and
what they found though is that the
excellent activation is not complete so
what you can see is we'll have some some
blue boxes here that are genes that
escape and activation and yellow boxes
referring to genes that are subject to
invest in activation and the first most
striking thing that they noticed is that
there was a distribution between these
two so it wasn't a complete yellow there
are several genes and in fact about 15
to 17 this case and activation in any
single individual you can see lots of
blue boxes kind of interspersed between
the yellow boxes so this really shows
that that X inactivation was not
complete and there's some proportion of
gene from the inactive X chromosome that
escaped the silencing mechanism
Maroubra they looked at nine individual
cell lines and what they found was even
more striking that not only is a finesse
addition not complete but it was
heterogeneous so we have the first cell
line and the second cell line here and
we're going to go through and look at
the third and the fourth six seven eight
nine and there's two things that show up
immediately from this is that when you
work across the team there are some
genes that are subject to new silencing
inactivation in all individual cell
lines that were actually done some day
excretion excitation and also a line
approximately 15% of the genes on the
inactive X escaped silencing in all
individual cell lines that were assayed
and the second thing that's important to
notice here is that there's a lot of
heterogeneity approximately 10% of the
genes on the X chromosome escape and
excitation in some individuals and not
in others this suggests that X
inactivation is a process that is still
evolving and we're going to show you why
we think that is and it comes down to
answering the question how did X
inactivation of all all right so I've
been asked to speak louder hopefully I
can do it now Don please let me know if
I'm not speaking loud enough
okay great so to get at our question of
how did X inactivation of all we wanted
to look at genes on the X and the y
chromosome because we don't think that
they evolved independently from each
other in genetic males who have one copy
of the X chromosome and one copy of the
Y chromosome we know that there are
variable categories of genes on the Y
chromosome so what we did is we took all
genes on the X chromosome that are
functional identify those that likely
existed in the ancestral X chromosome
and then categorize those functional
genes on the X based on the function of
their Y length copy and so we had three
categories and the first if there is a
subset of x-linked genes that have a
functional copy on the Y chromosome so
they have a gene on the X chromosome and
a functional gene on the Y the second
category are those that have a
functional copy on the x chromosome and
a pseudo denies copy on the Y chromosome
so this is a non functional copy but it
still has some relics of existing there
so we can identify sequence on the Y
chromosome even though we don't think
that it is functional and the third
category are excellent genes that have
no evidence of a wide linked copy but
we're confident based on comparative
genomics that these existed on the
ancestral X chromosome interest of X and
Y chromosome so they've been completely
lost from the Y chromosome which
suggests they were lost quite a long
time ago and the excellent genes of the
pseudo gene ice coffee were probably
lost not a very long time ago so then
let's go through and look at the X
inactivation status of each of these
categories and we're going to say are
those genes with a functional copy on x
and y subject to an activation or do
they escaped inactivation and so we see
first of all of eight if a gene has a
functional copy on the X and a
functional copy on the light those
escaped inactivation in all individual
cell lines that were assayed what this
means is that you have expression in two
copies in genetic female and two copies
and genetic males next when we look at
those genes that have a suit of
tonight's copy on the y chromosome
what we see is pretty striking and what
we see is that they have a functional
copy on the active x chromosome but on
the inactive x chromosome
these teams escaped inactivation in some
individuals and they do not escape
inactivation and others so they have a
heterogeneous escape from X inactivation
and what this suggests is that genes
that were recently citizen eyes it's
taken some time for a signal to get to
the other x chromosome to suggest that
this gene specifically should be
silenced and finally when we look at
excellent genes that have completely
lost their Y chromosome homolog so
there's absolutely no dosage on the y
chromosome in genetic mail we see that
they are almost always subject to
inactivation meaning you have one copy
expressed in males and one copy
expressed in genetic female so this
leads to a model of dosage compensation
and what we'll show here the two x
chromosomes and genetic females and the
X and the y chromosome in genetic males
and this is over a long evolutionary
time ancestrally there would be equal
dosage on the two x chromosomes in
genetic females and also equal dosage on
the X and the y chromosome prior to any
degradation on the y chromosome and then
what we will see is that for Y linked
genes that are certain eyes will see a
reduction in expression on the Y
chromosome and what we expect to happen
is a compensation with
upregulation on the X chromosome and
genetic mail for the X chromosome
doesn't exist in a vacuum so you'll also
have up regulation of those excellent
genes and genetic female then as the
process continues you'll continue to
have sewage and it's pseudo gen ization
of wide length genes and down regulation
of a wiling gene corresponding up
regulation of the X link stream and
female until the point where you have
tremendously high expression on the X
chromosome in both genetic females we
know from trisomies in humans that over
expression of genes can be do it serious
and so there might be some selection or
some sort the pressure acting to reduce
the expression of at least one copy of
the x in genetics in emails and so we
can get a sign limping mechanism
occurring gene by gene on the X
chromosome in response to gene loss on
the Y chromosome and what we'll see is
that over a long evolutionary time X
inactivation evolved in response to gene
loss on the Y chromosome so what's the
clinical relevance of studying X
inactivation will the fix it that it's
still an ongoing process evolution is
still shaping the pattern at X
inactivation the first is that we know
one of the X chromosomes is going to be
chosen randomly for silencing and it's
been shown in mouse models of disease
allele specifically fragile x syndrome
that if the fragile X chromosome the X
chromosome looks susceptibility to
fragile X is randomly chosen for
silencing in the appropriate tissues the
mouse will not show any of these
symptoms of fragile X however if the
alternative if the healthy chromosome is
chosen for silencing and the chromosome
with the susceptibility to fragile X is
active then you will get the phenotype
for fragile x syndrome
so when we're thinking about disease
risk the wheels we need to know on the
x-chromosome death machine escape and
activation not only across all
individuals in the population that we're
looking at but in particular individuals
that were concerned with sure that we
need to know about random whether we're
randomly silencing the functional or the
disease risk allele because of the
individuals may be heterozygous but
silencing may protect them from the
disease phenotype or it may make them
more susceptible to the disease
phenotype further some research recently
published has shown that exon activation
is heterogeneous within and between
tissues so work from Germany Nathan's
group has looked at tagging the X
chromosome with either a green or a red
fluorescent tag and this within a mouse
model and raising the mice up and then
looking at the patterns of inactivation
so I apologize if you're a red or green
colorblind I know we're talking about
the X chromosome and red-green color
blindness is linked to the X chromosome
but most of these studies use red and
green color tags so what I will tell you
if you cannot do this is that for the
corneal endothelium we see kind of
splattering of red and green all about
so it goes if I took a bag of jellybeans
red and green jelly beans and ice laid
them out on the ground I would see this
is approximately the pattern we see in
the corneal endothelium so there's a lot
of heterogeneity in this particular
tissue alternatively in the next image
we're looking at a cross-section of the
tongue and works fairly striking here
that approximately one half of the
tongue is green and approximately the
other half of the tongue is red
suggesting that the inactivation
occurred very early in the development
of the muscle tissue of the tongue
and perhaps the most striking and most
most provocative is a picture of a mouse
brain and in this one also we see nearly
1 hence there of the brain being read
and nearly one hemisphere of the brain
being green
so this television not only do we need
to understand the evolutionary history
of X inactivation we also need to
understand the developmental timing of X
inactivation in mice which are a model
for human disease as well as in human
world where X inactivation seems to play
a role in the development of certain
aggressive cancers so the bar body is
frequently lost meaning you have
reactivation of the X chromosome in many
aggressive breast and uterine cancers so
we've talked a lot about the X
chromosome and how the evolution of X
inactivation is shaped by degradation of
gene content on the y chromosome and
that might lead you to think that what's
left on the Y is not very important but
what I want to show is by looking at
population genetics of the Y chromosome
we show that the Y chromosome is
actually still very important and the Y
is worth studying so when we look at
genetic variation across him and y
chromosomes we see that not only if the
Y chromosome very small so it has
reduced gene content the genetic
variation is reduced Y chromosomes
across human populations are much more
similar to each other than we expect and
traditionally that's been attributed to
neutral processes or to selection and so
we're going to go through testing both
of these in the human population
and what we're going to look at first is
variance and reproductive success so a
neutral explanation for well why
diversity is that you just have fewer
males so nm is the effective number of
males in the population and if you have
high variance in male reproductive
success meaning that on average you have
fewer males contributing to the next
generation then we expect there to be
lower Y chromosome diversity and if we
look at the ratio of these if we have
the ratio of the effective number of
males to the effective number of females
who are equal reproductive success in
males and females if there is if that
ratio is less than one then we'll help
fewer males on average contributing to
the next generation which suggests lower
Y chromosome diversity and what we're
going to do if we're going to touch the
null hypothesis that this demography
these changes in the effective number of
males and females can explain low Y
chromosome diversity and the alternative
hypothesis that selection is also needed
to explain the Y chromosome diversity
across human populations so we looked at
whole genome Lee sequencing data we
thought there out sites that we thought
were under selection so we wouldn't be
biasing ourselves to begin with and
difficult to align regions and then with
most important about this study is that
well it's important to look at genetic
variation on the Y chromosome we also
need to know what's going on as far as
variation on the autosomes which are non
sex chromosomes on the x chromosome and
on the mitochondrial DNA so in this
study we looked at genetic variation or
pi the average number of pairwise
differences on the autosomes the X the Y
in the mitochondrial DNA and we
corrected for different mutation rates
on these different genomic regions and
then we're going to model variance in
reproductive success and we'll look at
equal reproductive success between
genetic males and genetic females with
this ratio of effective males to
effective females
one and then increasing skewed variants
and male reproductive success and then
we ran coalition simulation to test
these different models so what I want to
show is that we we replicated this in
both African populations and European
populations and for simplicity of
viewing we look at diversity on the X
the Y and the mitochondrial DNA relative
to B autosomes this gives a certain
expectation so approximately we expect
diversity on the x relative to the
autosomes to be 0.75 and armored y and
the mitochondria relative to the
autosomes we expect diversity to be
approximately 0.25 if there's no
variance in male reproductive success
and no selection and so what's
immediately obvious from these observed
values is that although variation on the
x relative to the autosomes is hovering
around 0.75 in both African and European
populations and it's very similar to
expectations in the mitochondrial DNA
which is passed through the genetic
female lineage we see the diversity on
the Y chromosome relative to the
autosomes is extremely reduced relative
to our expectations and so we'll run our
models and the first equal reproductive
success in males and females and we see
that that cannot explain the low Y
chromosome diversity and we don't expect
that it would we think that probably for
most of human history there's been at
least some bias and the effective
numbers of males relative to females and
then we'll run through the other models
looking at increasingly high variants of
male reproductive success so if we look
at
seventy five point five and point two
five we see that we can get a reduction
in the expected diversity on the Y
chromosome relative to the autosomes but
it never really reaches the low level
that we're expecting and so you might
imagine a scenario where we could look
at a very skewed effective number of
males relative to females so one male
reproducing for approximately every 100
females in the population but not only
if this not consistent with
anthropological evidence but if that
were the case then our model would not
fit the rest of the genome so we would
see that expected diversity on the x-ray
which of the autosomes would be
significantly higher and expected
diversity on the mitochondria relative
the autosomes would not match at all
what it is observed so what this tells
us is that demography alone is not
enough to explain lower Y chromosome
variation and this is perhaps not
surprising so we know that the Y
chromosome in addition to being very
small also does not undergo
recombination with the X chromosome and
so if purifying selection which reduces
genetic diversity is acting anywhere on
the right Y chromosome it will reflect
the length neutral sites but because
there's no recombination it will affect
the entire Y chromosome so what we
wanted to look at with different models
of purifying selection acting on the
human Y chromosome and suppose you're
purifying selection is when you have
selection purifying out harmful mutation
so mutations that disrupt a gene
function so to look at these models of
purifying selection on the y chromosome
we took an approximate likelihood
approach we looked at different
demography for the African and European
populations and look
to varying levels of purifying selection
and the first set of models we did was
trying to look at just at those simple
copy
coding sites on the y chromosome and
then the second was to estimate the
number of sites affected by purifying
selection if we allow the selection to
act on coding and non-coding or
regulatory regions of the y chromosome
and so the first is that if we look at
selection acting only on the coding
sites we couldn't find any models that
fit the data and so if we say that
natural selection is acting only on
those single copy coding sites on the y
chromosome we cannot find a model of
purifying selection that will reduce the
expected level of diversity to those
levels that we observe but what we know
is that while there's a small number of
coatings either on the y chromosome
there are many other sites on the Y
chromosome
so specifically here's a picture a
cartoon of the human Y chromosome and
these yellow regions are the extra
generate regions of the Y chromosome so
region that was shared between x and y
and then three regions are amplicon
Accor highly repetitive palindromic
regions these regions are expressed
nearly exclusively in the testes if they
are deleted it often leads to
spermatogenic failure so there's good
reason to think that these ample conic
regions may be affected by selection
more aware there's 5.7 mega bases of
ample conic regions on the y chromosome
which is significantly more than the
single copy coding regions so if we run
our models and try to approximate how
many sites are affected by selection on
the human Y chromosome what we find is
that with equal variance and male
reproductive success relative to females
or with a skewed variance in their
reproductive success relative to females
the expected
website perfected by selection is right
in between the total number of amplicon
excites and the coding sites on the y
chromosome so what does suggest is that
genes and the y chromosome are important
so its success that natural selection is
still acting on gene from the Y
chromosome and we should be concerned
with them the y chromosome is not a
degenerate well it is a little
degenerate but it's not unimportant and
the genes that are there still play an
important role in human health and so if
we think back a little more to the
clinical relevance of X and Y chromosome
variation just to reiterate the X
chromosome has fewer associations in
genome-wide Association studies you know
any other autosomal chromosome so even a
coma so me too is one-third the size of
the X chromosome it has four times as
many associations on it as the human X
chromosome 33 percent of genome-wide
Association studies report including the
X in their analysis part of this is
methodological but cause the X
chromosome it's not pregnant in two
copies and genetic males in genetics we
know it doesn't fit assumptions that of
methods that have been built for the
autosomes the Y chromosome has fewer
loci and zero associations in
genome-wide Association studies despite
a 1997 wad comas own consortium that
suggested the Y chromosome or
particularly Y chromosome haplotypes
were strongly indicated in heart disease
and because of what we've shown is that
these the cycle and y chromosome are are
not purely neutrally evolving that needs
a base selection acting on the Y
chromosome and we should probably figure
out what is really important about the
genes that are on the y chromosome
there's been some recent results
suggesting that loss of the y-chromosome
is highly implicated in development of
certain blood cancers including myeloma
this may be because of those few genes
that retain a copy that's functional on
the x and functional on the Y so if
there's been a lot of evolutionary
pressure that these genes escaped and
activation they have high dosage dosage
from two copies and genetic males and
genetic female it seems likely that
those are targets for human health and
disease are variants on the y chromosome
so what are the take-home messages
really that there's been gene loss on
the Y chromosome and in turn that's
informed or influenced the evolution of
inactivation of genes on one of the X
chromosomes for this process is ongoing
we see that there is heterogeneity
across inactivation across individuals
and we have yet little understanding of
how this varies across human populations
and to that the Y chromosome is still
functionally important it's not a
neutral marker it has functional genes
on it natural selection Darwin
natural selection is affecting genes on
the Y chromosome so what's important
from both of these is that evolution is
clinically relevant and just some
ongoing work in my lab is that we are
working on a computational detection of
a real specific expression so can we use
this to apply to whole transcriptome
studies to identify patterns of
inactivation across human populations
and can we also look at variation on the
Y chromosome to infer global genetic
ancestry so we also recently published a
paper in genome research that suggests
there was a bottleneck on the y
chromosome there coincides with global
changes and culture and so the
bottleneck may have also contributed to
the
the low genetic variation I'm a
y-chromosome all right and with that I
want to thank the school of Life
Sciences the Biodesign Institute and the
Center for evolution medicine here at
Arizona State University I was
previously funded by the NSF and the
Miller Institute for basic research and
recently by the Midland Foundation some
undergraduate research fellowships and
thank you to my collaborators on these
projects Caterina markova at Penn State
University Rasmus Nielsen at the
University of California Berkeley and
Khosla Muller at UCLA thank you dr.
Wilson sayers for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green join a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is what is the uniqueness
of 23 genes in the case of a male
Thanks that's an excellent question and
it was the first project that I started
working on as a graduate student so we
were interested in figuring out what is
unique about those genes that have
survived on the y chromosome and human
males and there's two answers to it the
first is that approximately half of
those genes are retained on the Y
chromosome across mammal so the x and y
chromosome that we have are shared
across all mammal if they were in the
common ancestor of youth eutherian and
also theory in mammals and approximately
half of them seem to have very
fundamental housekeeping roles they are
expressed in nearly all tissues they
escaped X inactivation if they are
deleted they lead to in viability of the
animal so for approximately half of them
they got stuck on this pair of autosomes
that became our sex chromosome and they
were so important that they could not be
lost the other half are genes that have
newly evolved since they became violent
male specific functions most often these
are things that are expressed
exclusively in the testes if they're
deleted they lead to infertility or in
viability of sperm often a sperm heads
won't form properly or they may not swim
properly so it seems like to be able to
survive on a human Y chromosome you
either need to be essential for life or
essential for reproduction
okay and are there any autosomal lo sign
knowing where one is active on one of
the homologous chromosomes but inactive
on the other
I II do autosomal analogues to X UNIVAC
inactivation exist so is there the same
kind of inactivation mechanism on the
autosomes no however there are genes
that are parentally imprinted so the
maternal allele may be imprinted meaning
when you inherit that allele from your
mother it will be silenced or the
paternal allele may be imprinted and
silenced we think the mechanism for this
is very different it's likely relates to
conflict over resource allocation in
particular one of the most notable cases
relates to I GE f2 growth factors and
parental imprinting leads to
differential rates of growth of the
offspring and so it seems that it kind
of evolved back and forth as a conflict
but but the same kind of dosage
compensation that we observe on the X
and Y chromosome does not appear to
apply to the autosomes
I think there's no more questions at
this point I want to thank everyone for
participating and please let me know if
you have any additional questions
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through November 13
2015 you will receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to Ford that announcement to your
colleagues may have missed today's live
event see you next time bye